Let's solve some more
rational equations.
So let's say I have x plus
1/x is equal to 2.
Once again, we have an x in a
denominator over here, it
looks kind of bizarre.
But you just have to remember,
if we multiply every term in
this equation by this
denominator, right here, by
this x, right there, then
essentially, you'll have x
times 1/x and the x will
disappear out of the
denominator.
So let's do that.
So we have to multiply every
term by that, you can't just
multiply one term.
So multiply this term times
x, this term times x,
and the 2 times x.
We're just multiplying both
sides of this equation by this
denominator.
So what do we get?
We get x times x is x squared
plus x times 1/x is just 1.
x's cancel out.
And then that's going
to be equal to 2x.
And this is starting
to look like our
standard quadratic equations.
We just have to subtract
2x from both sides.
And if we do that-- so let me
subtract 2x from there,
subtract 2x from there-- the
left-hand side of our equation
becomes x squared
minus 2x plus 1.
And the right-hand side
is equal to 0.
And we know how to solve
an equation like this.
We could either factor or use
the quadratic formula.
This actually seems pretty
straightforward to factor.
Negative 1 times negative
1 is 1.
Negative 1 plus negative
1 is negative 2.
So this is x minus 1 times
x minus 1 is equal to 0.
And we know, if two numbers,
when you multiply them, they
equal 0, that means one or both
of those numbers have to
be equal to 0.
In this situation, the number
is the same, right?
This is x minus 1 squared
is equal to 0, right?
So we know that x minus 1
has to be equal to 0.
Add 1 to both sides of this
equation and we get
x is equal to 1.
And you can verify it.
Verify that this works.
1 plus 1/1 does, indeed,
equal 2.
So it definitely does work.
Let's do a more involved one
now, now that we're warmed up.
Let's say I have 2 over x
squared plus 4x plus 3 is
equal to 2 plus x minus
2 over x minus 3.
So just like we've done in the
last problem and in all of the
other ones, we want to get all
of these x's out of the
denominator.
And the best way to do it is to
multiply every term in this
equation by-- you can view it
as the least common multiple
of the denominator.
So let me show you what
I'm talking about.
The first thing we might want
to do is factor this, to see
if this guy and this guy have
anything in common.
So let's see if we
can factor it.
What two numbers when you
multiply them equal 3 and when
you add them equal 4?
Well, 3 and 1, right?
So this right here, I can
rewrite it as x plus 3 and--
and really this is a plus
over there, too.
I wrote the original
problem wrong.
That is a [? product. ?]
So this over here on the left
is x plus 3 times x plus 1.
And so, what can we multiply
both sides of this equation by
to get rid of the x plus 3 and
an x plus 1 here, and an x
plus 3 over there?
Well, we multiply everything
by x plus 3 and
then by x plus 1.
So this expression right here is
actually divisible by this.
So the least common multiple of
x plus 3 and x squared plus
4x plus 3 is actually x squared
plus 4x plus 3,
because this is a multiple
of that.
It's divisible by it.
So let's multiply both sides
of the equation by this
expression, right here.
So we're going to get-- let me
just rewrite it-- x plus 3
times x plus 1-- and then we
have this term over here--
times 2 over x plus 3 times x
plus 1 is going to be equal to
x plus 3 times x plus 1 times
this 2 times that 2, over
there, plus x plus 3 times x
plus 1 times this term-- times
x minus 2 over x plus 3.
Now, the whole reason why we did
that is because that will
cancel with that.
The left-hand side of our
equation will just be a 2.
And 2 will be equal to-- well,
2 times this-- we know what
this is equal to-- x plus 3
times x plus 1 is x squared
plus 4x plus 3.
We know that.
We actually went
the other way.
We factored it.
So it's going to be 2 times x
squared plus 4x plus 3, which
is 2 times x squared is-- I'm
going to do it in that green
color so you know we're
dealing with
this 2 right here.
So this term right here is going
to be 2 times x squared.
So it's 2x squared plus 2
times 4x plus 8x plus 2
times 3 plus 6.
And now this term.
We have an x plus 3
in the numerator.
Or it would be, if I multiplied
it times this
fraction or this rational
expression.
That x plus 3 will cancel
with that x plus 3.
So we're just left with an x
plus 1 times an x minus 2.
An x plus 1 times x minus 2--
let me just focus in on this
expression right here.
I'll just box the whole thing.
x plus 1 times x minus 2 is,
let's just say it's x times x,
which is x squared.
x times negative 2, which
is negative 2x.
And then you have 1 times x, so
plus x, and then you have 1
times negative 2, so
you have minus 2.
And now we can simplify it.
So once again, the left-hand
side of this
equation is still 2.
Now on the right-hand side,
let's look at the x squared
terms. We have a 2x squared,
and we have an x squared.
Add them together, you
get 3x squared.
Then we have an 8x, and we
have a minus 2x plus x.
So what's that going to be?
This is an 8x, and then when
you add these together, you
just get a minus-- you just
get a negative x.
So when you add everything
together, you're going
to get a plus 7x.
Those are the x terms. And then
finally, you have a-- no,
I already used the orange--
you have a 6 and you
have a minus 2.
So that's going to be plus 4.
And now let's subtract 2 from
both sides of this equation.
Let's subtract 2 from
both sides.
And we are left with 0 is equal
to 3x squared plus 7x.
We are subtracting 2 from both
sides, so 4 minus 2 is plus 2.
So we've stumbled, then we've
turned this bizarre-looking
thing into kind of
a standard, plain
vanilla quadratic equation.
We have a non-zero coefficient
out here.
We might-- well, we just
want to solve for it.
We actually don't even
have to factor it.
So we might as well just use
the quadratic formula.
That's the easiest way to solve,
especially a quadratic
equation that has a non-one
coefficient on
the x squared term.
So our solutions, using the
quadratic formula. x is going
to be equal to negative b--
which is negative 7-- plus or
minus the square root of b
squared-- that's 7 squared--
which is 49 minus 4 times
a-- which is 3--
times c, which is 2.
All of that over 2 times
a, over 2 times 3 is 6.
So what does this equal to?
4 times 3 is 12 times 2 is 24.
So that, right there, is 24.
What's 49 minus 24?
It's 25.
So I don't want to make
that too messy, so
let me rewrite it.
So x is equal to negative 7 plus
or minus the square root
of 49 minus 24 is 25 over 6,
which is equal to negative 7
plus or minus 5-- the square
root of 25-- over 6.
And let's see, if we were to add
5, that would be negative
7 plus 5 is negative
2 over 6, which is
equal to negative 1/3.
That is one solution.
And then if I do negative 7
minus 5, that is negative 12
over 6, which is equal
to negative 2.
So those are our two solutions
to this original rational
equation right up here.
Hopefully you enjoyed that.